bonjour et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
édition du 78 lactu édition du vendredi
13 septembre voici les principaux titres
13 millions et 27 millions d'euros c'est
le montant des cagnottes du Super Loto
et de l'euromillion aujourd'hui vendredi
1 oblige allezvous tenter votre chance
c'est ce que nous verrons la
Confédération de l'artisanat et des
petites entreprises du bâtiment appelait
à une mobilisation nationale dès ce
matin pour sauver le secteur du bâtiment
opération escargot sur les routes du
département avant de se rendre en
préfecture nous reviendrons également
sur cette semaine de contestation force
de l'ordre fonctionnaire étaiit aussi
dans la rue pour notamment s'opposer à
la réforme des
retraites l'image du jour à présent
c'est l'ouverture ce soir vendredi 13
des 30e journée du patrimoine qui marque
également les 100 ans de la loi de
protection du patrimoine 16000 sites
public ou privé ouvert dans les ivelines
musée de la ville château de Versailles
préfecture sont à visiter pour en savoir
plus sur le programme rendez-vous avec
kiosk le magazine culturel de la
rédaction à l'antenne notamment
aujourd'hui à 20h30 et puis en replay
également sur notre site internet on
reste dans le patrimoine avec le château
de Versailles qui se lance dans
l'épicerie fine une gamme de produits
vient d'être dévoilé des fruits des
légumes ou encore des bonbons et des
confitures exemple de prix 11,90 € pour
un sirop de Lavand à la vanille cette
licence doit permettre de diversifier
les ressources de
l'établissement du sirop de la vente des
nefle ou encore des panets autant
d'aliments oubliés des cuisines que vous
n'avez certainement jamais dégusté et
pourtant sous le règne de Louis XIV ces
produits étaient dans toutes les
assiettes le château de Versailles lance
sa gamme épicerie fine et veut leur
redonner vie tous les nouveaux fruits et
légumes que nous mangeons aujourd'hui
euh ont été introduit à Versailles par
jeanmth la Cantini des pratiques comme
le foie gras euh ont été ortés par euh
par Louis XIV des le le sucre les
bonbons les sirops ont été développé
sous le règne de Louis XIV cette gamme
épicerie fine est également un moyen
pour Versailles d'exporter son
savoir-faire à travers le monde avec 75
% de visiteurs étrangers le château veut
rayonner en dehors de nos frontières
grâce à la gastronomie
royale ça fait partie des atouts de la
France ça fait partie des points forts
de la France et nous à Versailles
puisqu'on est l'emblème de la France et
bien on se doit aussi de savoir exporter
la
gastronomie exporter des produits qui
certains amateurs seront peut-être déçus
ne sont pas 100 % versaillais mais son
bio est cultivé dans le sud-ouest de la
France pour les déguster il vous en
coûtera en moyenne entre 7 et 15 € la
pièce à l'occasion de ce lancement nous
avons longuement rencontré Catherine
péar et la présidente de l'établissement
public du château de Versailles Anthony
RCH a échangé avec elle autour de cette
initiative pour le moins original mais
aussi à propos des prochains projets les
images sont signées Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude Catherine péard bonjour vous
êtes président de l'établissement public
du du château de versaill vous lancez
aujourd'hui votre marque d'épicerie F
première question quand et comment est
né ce projet mais ce projet est né d'une
rencontre avec Bernard Lafond qui
travaille sur ses produits oubliés ses
légumes ses végétaux ses ses fruits
quelquefois des fruits tout simples
quelquefois des fruits plus compliqués
quelquefois des fruits qui ont été
abandonnés au fil des générations et
donc qui nous a proposé un projet qui
nous a semblé très cohérent puisqu'il se
réfère à l'histoire du goût et à
l'histoire de la gastronomie et que nous
évidemment nous cherchons toujours quand
quand nous essayons d'innover dans ce
21e siècle parce que comme vous m'avez
souvent entendu le dire Versailles n'est
pas un musée figé dans le passé versaill
est un château qui vit dans son époque
avec des publics nouveaux avec des
publics différents qui viennent ici avec
des rêves et aussi avec une culture qui
n'est pas for forcément la nôtre et donc
il faut savoir leur parler de versaill
parfois autrement pas seulement à
travers ce grand livre d'histoire que
que nous ouvrons tous les jours mais
aussi à travers l'art de vivre le style
et la gastronomie et la gastronomie
c'est un nouveau point d'entrée pour
venir à Versailles déguster des produits
qui bien sûr ne sont pas produits ici
mais qui souvent ont été mangés à
d'autres époques ici même quel type de
produit on va pouvoir trouver alors il y
a des produits très amusants qu'on ne
connaît pas par exemple vous trouvez des
jus de lavande on n pas du tout idée que
on va trouver un jus de lavande on va
trouver une gelée de safran on va
trouver bien sûr du foie gras parce que
Monsieur Lafond vient du Sud-Ouest et je
crois qu'il n'aurait pas survécu au fait
de ne pas travailler le foie gras et
puis des des des nefles par exemple on
ne parlait plus des nefles on va trouver
des nefles des confitures des bonbons
parce que les reinnes pas seulement
Marie-Antoinette les reines mangaient
souvent beaucoup de bonbons et beaucoup
de douceur et bien c'est tout ce petit
monde qui se recrée et votre volonté
avec cette marque d'épicerie F c'est de
vous exporter oui parce que vous savez
nous avons 75 % de visiteurs étrangers
nous avons de plus en plus de touristes
qui viennent de nouveaux pays comme la
Chine comme le Brésil comme l'Australie
et bien ils arrivent ici évidemment avec
un rêve de Versailles avec des idées sur
Versailles et mais aussi avec leur
propre culture et ils viennent vers nous
et nous nous devons aller vers eux et
exporter Versailles à l'étranger c'est
aussi exporter ce savoir-faire le
savoir-faire de nos métiers d'art euh le
et l'art de vivre le savoirvvre à
travers aussi ces produits gastronomique
tout ça forme un tout il y a pas
seulement d'un côté les tissus et puis
les bénisteries et puis l'esthétique au
sens le plus large du terme non il y a
aussi la gastronomie ça fait partie des
atouts de la France ça fait partie des
points forts de la France et nous à
versaill puisqu'on est l'emblème de la
France et bien on se doit aussi de
savoir exporter la gastronomie en
attendant le lancement de l'épicerie
fine cet été c'est bien passé au château
cet été c'est très bien passé alors
aujourd'hui nous retrouvons le premier
jour de plui qui je l'espère qui ne
signe pas la fin de la saison puisque
les grandes eau continuent encore
jusqu'au 14 septembre les grandes eau
nocturnes il faut venir profiter des
derniers moments pour voir ces grandes
eau qui sont quand même le spectacle le
plus prisé à Versailles pendant tout
l'été et nous avons eu la chance
d'accueillir encore plus de visiteurs
que l'an dernier 8% de plus en juillet
en août qu'en juillet en août l'an
dernier et je crois 5 % de plus depuis
le mois de janvier dernière question
quand on voit bah cette création de
marque d'épicerie F on se dit qu'il y a
peut-être d'autres idées qui vont
arriver bientôt pour essayer encore
d'exporter un peu
plus peux pas tout vous dire aujourd'hui
là aujourd'hui c'est l'pistriffine et
puis bien sûr à travers des marques à
travers des liens encore une fois
cohérents je j'insiste sur ce mot parce
que l'idée c'est que il y ait un lien
entre l'histoire entre le patrimoine et
entre les créations d'aujourd'hui et par
exemple nous allons aller dans quelques
jours voir ça c'est à scou voir le
lustre que font les bouroulek les frères
bouroulek sont en train de faire un
lustre pour versaill qui sera installé
dans l'escalier Gabriel donc une œuvre
contemporaine à Versailles et bien là
c'est aussi une autre manière de parler
de versaill autrement et de montrer la
création d'aujourd'hui dans le
patrimoine
entre 6 et 8 millions de joueurs
attendus aujourd'hui vendredi 13 super
loto Euromillion ont la faveur de ceux
qui vont tenter leur chance avec des
gains pouvant aller jusqu'à 27 millions
d'euros ferez-vous partie de ceux qui
vont succomber à l'appel de la Française
des jeux vos réponses au micro de Michel
Jarry bien sûr donc on doit jouer au
loto bah oui ça va for T chance je
essayer ça tout à l'heure après ma
rentrée je va aller acheter un ticket de
loto et puis on verra moi vendredi 13
j'ai jamais porté d'importance à cette
journée toujours trouvé c'est un peu
futile je crois pas vraiment à toutes
ces choseslà enfin que ce soit
portechance et porte malheur non pas
vraiment je pense pas que ça a une vraie
influence je suis pas trop superstitieux
donc je me dis que c'est un jour comme
les autres mais que si ça porte chance à
d'utre personne pourquoi pas 8 ans de
travaux le lycée jean-pin à sainsire à
l'école à connu plus qu'un léger lifting
la fin des travaux a été inauguré
mercredi en présence de Jean-Paul Huchon
le président socialiste de la région
île-de-fance le point sur tout ces
changements également sur la nouvelle
offre de formation avec yolen Torz et
lodim moine Jean-Paul Huchon tenait à
être présent et pour cause cela fait 8
ans que le lycée jean-pin était en
travaux le président PS de la Région
Île-de-France ne voulait pas manquer
l'inauguration 1 2 et 3
bra le conseil régional a investi 34
millions d'euros pour la réfection du
bâtiment un bâtiment qui date des les
années 60 et qui souffrait de problèmes
de sécurité et d'espace le temps des
travaux les élèves étaient accueillis
dans des préfabriqués pas toujours en
bon état des problèmes aujourd'hui
résolus on a eu des soucis en
l'informatique et puis là là ça va mieux
les locaux aussi niveau température
c'était pas trop ça maintenant on est
mieux donc ça incite vraiment à à mieux
travailler c'est c'est propre et ça
donne envie de travailler ça donne envie
de rentrer de venir tous les matins
d'aller en C
deux bâtiments ont été gardés et rénovés
celui du milieu a été reconstruit pour
assurer une meilleure liaison résultat
des locaux beaucoup plus fonctionnels et
un accès pour les handicapés facilité de
quoi donner de belles perspectives à la
proviseur du lycée j'espère bien
remonter les effectifs et changer
l'image aussi de l'établissement sur la
commune
l'intercommunalité voir le département
puisque nous avons des
filières exclusives dans le département
marchandisage visuel n'existe que au
lycée jean-in de même que l'optique
c'est le seul lycée public du
département à offrir une filière optique
ici le magasin pédagogique véritable
réplique d'un commerce où les élèves
conseillent de vrais clients ils
viennent avec leur feuill de maladie et
bénéficient de tarifs préférentiels sur
les lunettes l'établissement ne compte
pas s'arrêter là l'ouverture d'un BTS
dans le domaine est actuellement à
l'étude bientôt un Nouel l'Institut
d'études politiques dans le département
des Yvelines ce sera le premier à être
créé depuis 20 ans en France le premier
également dans la région île-de- France
il ouvrira en septembre 2014 à
Saint-Germain en la l'un de ses points
forts la diversité des langues
enseignées comme va nous l'expliquer son
directeur adjoint professeur à
l'Université de sa-quentin en iveline
université à l'origine du projet avec
celle de Sergy Pontoise on va essayer de
mettre en place un partenariat très
important avec le lycée international de
Saint-Germain en laai ce qui nous per
permettra de proposer à nos étudiants un
très grand nombre de langues étrangèr ce
qui est toujours une très bonne chose
dans les en tout cas beaucoup plus que
ce que les IEP proposent classiquement
même ce que l'IEP Paris est capable de
proposer il faut se démarquer par
rapport aux autres instituts d'études
politiques est-ce qu'il y a une
concurrence entre les instituts d'études
politiques je sais pas s'il y a une
vraie concurrence aujourd'hui il y a une
concurrence qui existe entre les
universités universitésou V c'est vrai
mais entre les IEP c'est peut-être moins
vrai d'ailleurs on a été très très bien
accueilli par les 6 IEP de région pierre
mathieio qui dirige l'IEP de Lille a été
un véritable par unmoral pour nous donc
là-dessus il y a pas eu vraiment de
problème vous savez je dirais le gâteau
est assez large pour qu'on se le partage
voilà pour cet entretien réalisé cette
semaine au cours d'une précédente
édition du 78 lactu politique toujours
cette fois-ci avec le président de
l'agglomération de cquanttin en Yveline
le socialiste Robert Cadalbert qui vient
de dresser ses priorités pour les
prochains mois commencer par l'emploi de
des jeunes mais également un coup
d'accélérateur au projet
économique la rentrée sera économique ou
ne sera pas c'était le maître mot de la
conférence qu'a tenu ce jeudi le
président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de saint-quanttin en
iveline Robert Cadalbert tout d'abord
1000 emplois supplémentair avec
l'arrivée du nouveau siège social de
Mercedes France à montigy le Bretonneux
la pose de la fameuse étoile emblème de
la marque est fixée à la fin novembre
toujours des emplois supplémentaires
cette fois du côté du Crédit Agricole
une extension est prévue pour accueillir
1000 salarié en plus la pose de la
première pierre à guilloncour qui
lancera le chantier est fixé au 22
octobre autre nouvelle elle concerne le
technoentre Renault aguyoncour un projet
de rapprochement des sites franciliens
vers le Pôl yvelinois est envisagé cela
semble se confirmer des collaborateur du
site de RIL mal maison devrait commencer
à arriver enfin la vente des terrains
pour la création de l'école d'ingénieur
estaka à Montini a été signé à la fin du
mois d'août la pose du premier arbre
symbole là encore du lancement du
chantier est prévu le 15 novembre les
jeunes une priorité pour le président de
l'agglomération qui s'est fixé un
objectif très ambitieux qu'aucun jeune
5quantinois ne sorte du système scolaire
sans un contrat c'est une logique
atteignable estimet-il tout le monde sa
veut dire d'abord le tissu économique de
saintanttin vin avec des acteurs le club
face qui effectivement travaille dans
l'insertion des jeunes dans l'entreprise
on fait en sorte que tous les contrats
d'apprentissage puisse effquement
trouver des des des des entreprises on
fait que les les emplois d'avenir
que l'école la deuxème chance que Pôle
Emploi tout le monde avec la cité des
cité des métier sous l'égide importante
de la Mission locale qui fait un
excellent travail aujourd'hui travaill
ensemble des bonnes nouvelles qui ne
font pas oublier deux dossiers sociaux
du moment la session de rware le centre
informatique d'Areva Guill encour les
syndicats sont très mobilisé sur la
question et la restructuration du groupe
EADS implanté notamment à la clé
Saint-Pierre à est en
cours des élus ruraux en colère en cause
le durcissement de la loi de solidarité
urbaine ces rues qui prévoit d'instaurer
dans les prochaines années un quôat de
logements sociaux de 25 % pour les
communes de 1500 habitants le député des
yvelin jean- Frédéric poisson du Parti
Chrétien déémocrate entend faire amender
le texte quant à Yve vendeval le
président du parc naturel de la Haute
Vallée de Chevreuse conseiller général
également UMP il estime que cela va
défigurer des espaces protégés il doit
rencont lundi le ministre de
l'Environnement c'est une sorte de
bavure législative si je puis dire
l'obligation de construire des logements
sociaux dans de toute petite commune
rurale ne correspond évidemment pas à la
volonté réelle du législateur c'est la
combinaison de plusieurs textes de lois
dans le temps je peux pas rentrer dans
les détails ici qui fait que
effectivement quelques communes rurales
comme CERN la ville par exemple qui ont
fait le choix d'entrer dans la
communauté de communes de Rambouillet se
trouve du jour au lendemain soumise à
l'obligation de construire 25 % de
logements sociaux elles auraient choisi
d'aller à Chevreuse elles seraent aller
à la Communauté de Communes des étants
elles ne seraiit pas soumise à cette
obligation c'est donc je dirais une
bavure législative et ce que nous
souhaitons c'est que par voie
d'amendement et nous comptons sur les
parlementaires évilinois pour le faire
que par voie d'amendement on corrige
effectivement ce qui constitue une
erreur dans la loi la semaine a été
marquée par la contestation sociale à
commencé par celle des policiers dès
lundi qui ne verbalisait pas les auteurs
d'infraction légère à la circulation et
au stationnement opération nationale
organisé ici à versaill une action menée
à l'appel du syndicat Alliance police
nationale afin de contester le projet de
réforme des retraites mais aussi le
projet de réforme pénale des faux PV
expliquant leurs revendications ont
aussi été distribuées dans le détail ils
souhaitent une meilleure prise en compte
de la pénibilité de leur métier et côté
justice que l'incarcération devienne une
règle le syndicat Alliance parle de
l'xisme et de hausse probable de la
délinquence avec ce projet de réforme on
écoute l'un des représentants de ce
syndicat à propos de cette opération
inédite qui a été mené lundi c'est pas
quelque chose de courant et c'est
surtout que c'est une autre façon de
faire qu'une traditionnelle
manifestation de rue c'est une façon
pour nous de mobiliser nos collègues
mais aussi d'attirer et d'avoir la
sympathie de la population pour nous
soutenir et pour se pour soutenir sa
police nationale la réforme des
retraites qui mobilisait aussi les
fonctionnaires mardi à l'appel de la CGT
ils étaient quelques 300000 selon le
syndicat à défilé dans les rues de Paris
155000 selon le ministère de l'Intérieur
dans l'éducation la grève a été peu
suivi dans les Yvelines l'inspection
académique annonce seulement 1 % de
professeurs absents dans le primaire 2 %
dans le
secondaire mobilisation des salariés le
mardi des forces de l'ordre le lundi et
enfin des chefs d'entreprise du secteur
du bâtiment ce vendredi les artisans du
bâtiment crient aussi leur ralbol ils se
sont mobilisés dans toute la France ce
matin pour alerter les pouvoirs publics
sur les difficultés de leur secteur un
secteur qui représente plus de 700000
salariés l'augmentation de la TVA prévu
pour pour le 1er janvier 2014 les
inquiètes elle passera de 7 à 10 % et
pourrait impacter le pouvoir d'achat de
leurs clients selon eux il réclame aussi
la sortie du statut auto-entrepreneur de
ce secteur à la préfecture de Versailles
ce matin le président de la
Confédération de l'artisanat des
evelines avait rendez-vous avec le
cabinet du préfet ce qu'on leur demande
c'est de remonter auprès du président de
la République qu'il se rendre compte que
voilà c'est pas un mouvement de quelques
farfelues c'est vraiment l'intégralité
du du bâtiment qui qui est en colère et
et et qui veut sortir de cette situation
et qu'on l'aide on demande pas de
subvention hein on demande juste qu'on
arrête de nous
fiscaliser le gouvernement et la
Fédération des établissements
hospitaliers et d'aide à la personne
privée non lucratif ont signé cette
semaine une convention pour le
recrutement de 1500 emplois d'avenir
trois ministres dont livelinois Benoît
amont se sont rendus à l'Institut MGEN
de la verrière pour cette signature dans
cet établissement si jeunes ont déjà été
recruté comme brancardi avec ce statut à
la clé un CDD de 30 mois et une
formation danst les ivelines on
comptabiliserait 700 emplois
d'avenir 1500 emplois d'avenir d'ici fin
2014 c'est ce que promet la féap la
fédération regroupant les organismes
sociaux médicau-privés à but non
lucratif pour marquer cet engagement
trois ministres se sont rendus à La
Verrière dans une unité de soins
gériatrique ici six jeunes ont été
recrutés comme brangardiers beaucoup ont
enchaîné des petits boulots avant de
s'engager dans le milieu médical avec
ses contrats d'avenir ils obtiennent un
CDD de 30 mois et une formation ça
change que j'ai un avenir plus sûr vous
voyez ce que je veux dire donc c'est
PASAT c'est c'est bien ça pour les
jeunes l'État s'engage de son côté à
financer une partie des salaire à
hauteur de 75 % du SMIC ainsi que la
formation pour la FAP ces aides
facilitent grandement le recrutement en
toutous les cas c'est une initation
extrêmement forte et qui doit qui fait
que on ne peut pas passer à côté mais je
ne sais pas répondre à la question de
savoir si on aurait employé on aurait
probablement employé moins c'est tout à
fait clair l'objectif reste cependant de
reconduire ces nouvelles recrues une
fois formé en CDI dans les ivelines on
comptabiliserait aujourd'hui près de 700
emploi d'avenir le gouvernement espère
atteindre les 100000 embauches en France
d'ici la fin de l'année et ce secteur de
la santé et du médico-social et
particulièrement porteur en terme
d'emploi actuellement malgré la crise
avec le vieillissement de la ultion les
besoins augmentent comme l'a expliqué
lors de cette signature Marie sol Touren
la ministre des Affaires sociales et de
la santé il y a plus de 50000 emplois
d'avenir d'ors et déjà signés 52000 fin
août et fin juillet il y avait 11000
emplois d'avenir signé dans les trois
secteurs de la santé du médico-social et
du social c'est donc une part très
significative qui représente même près
du tiers des emplois signés si l'on
exclut l'éducation nationale donc on
voit qu' il y a une mobilisation forte
des acteurs de la santé il y a aussi des
besoins forts dans le domaine de la
santé dans le domaine social économie
les clubs d'affaires qui permettent aux
chefs d'entreprise de se retrouver se
multipli certains se différencient
parfois c'est le cas de la PE Business
Club à 50 ans en Yveline tourner vers la
culture première réunion qui se
déroulait à lundi soir Catherine zulato
Patrick JAC de
dixmud un nouveau Club d'Affaires à
Saint-Quentin en Eveline le Happy Hour
Business Club un club pour réunir entre
eux chefs d'entreprise avec une
orientation autour de la culture une
fois par mois les adhérents se
retrouvent à Montini pour suivre une
conférence ils peuvent également
assister à des avant-premières de film
et de spectacles et puis toujours à
l'issue de ces événements l'occasion de
partager un verre ensemble un peu de
culture sur cquentin la culture elle est
quand même
particulièrement mis en avant on a pas
se plaindre faut faut pas exagérer on a
tout ce qu'il
faut et puis en même temps garder le
côté Club d'Affaires je vois ce soir bah
les gens ils discutent ils s'échangent
des cartes c'est comme ça qu'on fait du
business et du vrai business sympa ce
mardi soir invité de la première
conférence Etienne Greger professeur à
HC et adepte de la pensée positive venu
délivrer des conseils aux chefs
d'entreprise présents il faut faire
confiance
affirme-t-il la confiance est au est au
cœur des affaires il y a une dimension
autoréalisatrice de la confiance qui
fait que quand les gens ont confiance
ils investissent ils consomment et ça
crée un site le vertueux et à contrario
quand vous êtes dans un cycle de une
spirale de de défiance bah Vous vous
vous bloquez tout ce qui s'est passé en
2008 au demant la prochaine conférence
aura lieu le 8 octobre autour du thème
du handicap et de la réussite Happy Hour
Business Club compte à ce jour une
vingtaine de membres plusieurs
cotisations sont proposées premier tarif
d'adhésion à partir de 200 € par
an équations je vous redonne l'une des
informations principales de ce 13
septembre les artisans du bâtiment qui
crie aussi leur ralbol ils se sont
mobilisés ce matin dans en toute la
France pour alerter les pouvoirs publics
sur les difficultés de leur secteur un
secteur qui représente plus de 700000
salariés l'augmentation de la TVA prévu
pour le 1er janvier 2014 les inquiète
elle passera de 7 à 10 % et pourrait
impacter le pouvoir d'achat de leurs
clients selon eux il réclament aussi la
sortie du statut auto-entrepreneur de ce
secteur à la préfecture de Versailles ce
vendredi matin le président de la
Confédération de l'artisanat des
Yvelines avait rende-v avec le cabinet
du préfet on
l'écoute qu'on leur demande c'est de
remonter auprès du président de la
République qu'il se rendent compte que
voilà c'est pas un mouvement de quelques
farfelu c'est vraiment l'intégralité du
du bâtiment qui qui est en colère et et
qui veut sortir de cette situation et
qu'on l'aide on demande pas de
subvention hein on demande juste qu'on
arrête de nous fiscaliser fin du journal
de la rédaction de ce 13 septembre on se
retrouve lundi 18h en direct il sera
notamment question de la semaine de la
mobilité une semaine européenne pour
bouger autrement qui mobilisera
plusieurs communes des ivelines dont
celle de CTIN cyclistes utilisateurs des
services d'autopartage des transports en
commun sont à l'honneur plusieurs
animations annoncées et également
l'inauguration de la gare rénovée de
Montini le Bretonneux on en parlera dès
lundi dans le 78 lactu passer un bon
weekend même s'il s'annonce plus vieux
et je vous retrouve lundi bonne
soirée